et moi mon objectif c'est l'arrêté
t'aurais pas qu'au moment où au moment
où café correspond plus à ce que
j'attends et que les clients attendaient
c'est un savoir-faire que thomas
pratique tous les matins depuis dix ans
la torréfaction un processus qui demande
précision et concentration de 15 à 20
minutes de cuisson selon le grain et la
saveur souhaité le café pendant cette
crise on va subir plusieurs processus
il va prendre
ses arômes bien entendu il va perdre du
poids puisque l'aube à s'évaporer et il
va aussi prendre en volume elles d'asie
en amérique du sud le voyage dans les
saveurs est ici permanent 15 café sont
ainsi torréfié avec des mélanges maison
et une volonté éco-responsable
indissociable des choix des stèles et
thomas on part d'un principe très simple
c'est que si on veut quelque chose de
qualité il faut qu'on ait les
plantations et les fermes qui qu'ils
soient investis dans leur dans leurs
productions et cet investissement va se
retrouver aussi haut niveau au niveau de
l'écologie et au niveau de l'humain
preuve de la qualité des produits servis
thomas a reçu en 2010 le prix du
meilleur torréfacteur de france
seulement quatre ans après l'ouverture
du magasin
un titre qui récompense aussi
l'investissement total d'un couple
l'objectif c'était de deux secrétaires
nouveau choix de vie 2
de s'investir dans un projet que
comportaient tous les deux et et
d'évoluer dans un brin l'univers et dans
un métier qui nous plaisait qui nous
faisait que le matin en se levant pour
aller travailler on avait plus plus
envie plus de plaisir que que les
précédents mais quiconque on faisait et
qui correspondait peut-être moins anoma
nos envies à nos profils sans formation
et sans connaissance particulière du
café en 2006 ils sont en 2010 est connu
et reconnu de la vie locale
ils vont aussi près de 120 références
doté pour leur dixième saison les
torréfacteurs vie sinon à propose une
série d'animations ce jour la vente de
sacs à café au profit d'une ong peut
retrouver les numéros de lots l'origine
le poids
net donc on est un petit peu c'est
l'équivalent un peu de la bouteille de
vin en france voilà alors on fait pas de
magie on a les petits commerçants leurs
propres limites notamment d'un des
contraintes économiques c'est évident
mais voilà ça ça apporte
beaucoup de bonheur dans le quotidien
d'une petite boutique beaucoup de
bonheur aussi pour les clients du
magasin tous séduits par la démarche éco
responsable de l'animation
je trouve ça très très généreux de leur
parc et surtout c'est vrai que c'est ne
se démontre un esprit d'ouverture
je trouve le concept génial sont plus
adaptés par rapport à leur activité donc
voilà je viens de faire une demi heure
de route pour pour venir chercher des
sacs pour continuer à fêter leur passion
du café estelle et thomas proposeront
des animations jusqu'en juillet autour
du biscuit et de l'apéritif deux
thématiques comme le café à consommer
avec sagesse